[Music]
the antidote to our problems in this
country when it comes to judges and
politics is not to deny you a place on
the Supreme Court this is exactly where
you need to be this is exactly the time
you need to be there and I am Telling
President Trump you do some things that
drive me crazy you do some great things
you have never done anything better in
my view than to pick gorsek and
Cavanaugh because you had an opportunity
to put well-qualified conservatives on
the court men steeped in the rule of law
who will apply analysis not politics or
the decision-making and you not get out
of the part in to my friends on the
other side you can't lose the election
and pick judges if you want to pick
judges you better win no Obama used to
tell us that Lindsey Graham hammering
Senate Democrats for their outrageous
behavior at today's hearing also
breaking tonight the New York Times
reporting robert muller will accept some
written answers from the president does
this mean the investigation is going to
come to an end ever finally nearly 500
days here to weigh in on all of this is
the president's attorney also the chief
counsel for the American Center for Law
and Justice Jay Sekulow who has done
legal work for me in the past and we
actually had broke bread together and
you know you talk once about sports good
to see you how are you let's start good
you've argued before the Supreme Court
personally what 12 times yep yeah you
see LJ sometimes yep and you want most
of your cases right we've been very
fortunate very blessed in that regard
you don't win them all but we've won a
overwhelming majority and if you include
the others you mentioned we've had a
number of cases that have been summarily
reversed we've had a good track record
with look I've also won these cases some
of them we've won unanimously a number
of them unanimously it depends on the
nature of the case but I got to tell you
something that the president has made
two fantastic picks Neil Gorsuch
tremendous judge now justice Brett
Kavanaugh who I've known for a long time
is is brilliant is a you've been a great
judge and if you want to know anything
about Brett cab and I'll read his 312
that may be a good way to start so you
saw theatrics today in the Senate but at
the end of the day guess what happens
judge Kavanagh becomes justice Cavanaugh
and it's confirmed to the Supreme Court
of the United States and the president
gave a great selection with both of
these justices I mean in reshaping the
court literally for decades with a
conservative judicial philosophy Lindsey
Graham said at elections in that context
have consequences and here the selection
of Brett Kavanaugh is I think there's
probably the most qualified really sad
judge out there for this position
you know orchestration that went on
today those two young girls that went in
a courtroom that they had to watch their
dad go through that you know that
process nearly said it I was really
careful all right let me let me move but
Brett Kavanaugh his opening statement
those Sean I thought Brett Cavanaugh's
opening statement and what the president
tweeted out about what was going on in
the Senate kind of summed it all up are
they are these senators really going to
tangle with Brett Kavanaugh because let
me tell you who wins that one Brett
Kavanaugh is that I think it's a fait
accompli it's interesting to watch yeah
New York Times headline Muller will
accept some written answers for Trump
it's been a number a week since you and
your legal team responded to the special
counsel
some were wondering if there's going to
be a fight whether they would subpoena
the president may still happen tell us
what you can about what this means and I
know there's only so much you can say
yeah and I've got to be very obviously
very careful so let me tell you this we
have an ongoing dialogue with the Office
of Special Counsel myself and our
colleagues continuing an ongoing
dialogue that dialogue continues I'm not
going to discuss the the contents of
what has been agreed to or not agree to
but I will tell you this I'm not
concerned about the President of the
United States
responding if we decide to accept the
proposition of responding to written
questions responding to questions about
Russia and interference with the
election
there's no president's committed there's
no crime here there's no underlying
crime that the president was involved in
I'm not concerned about where that goes
look I mean it may if they ask questions
and we think they're appropriate we
would respond again we haven't even
responded to the special counsel it's a
white House Counsel letter but it's a
the White House Council spent 30 hours
testifying before which which to me is
mind-blowing but it seems to me this if
in fact on McGann gave him 30 hours and
if the president would have go in and
say one thing contradictory did what
McGann said that then sets him up for a
perjury trap and every lawyer
well let's you're jumping to your
jumping way ahead of the discussion to
go to what happens if there was an
interview we're not in interview because
but we said it's very important
this White House has been the most
transparent in history when it comes to
investigations or inquiries like this
you mentioned I'm against 30 hours of
testimony there's been 30 other
witnesses that the White House put
forward to testify there's been over 1.4
million pages of documents that have
gone forward so the idea that the
special counsel has not been given
access to information I think they would
be readily admit that this has been a
transparent investigation and a
transparent inquiry there's all this
medias been going on about what was said
or what wasn't said but let me tell you
this the president United States
authorized his legal team both as White
House Counsel and his private lawyers to
engage this in a transparent basis and
that's been done this does need to come
to an end I mean I think everybody in
the country wants us to come to an end I
don't give dates and times it needs to
happen sooner rather than later but look
at the end of the day as I said it's a
process of negotiation it's ongoing I'm
not going to disclose the nature of that
but there's been a lot of speculation in
the media today I will tell you this
much look at what has happened so far
and what the number of documents and the
number of witnesses that have gone
forward do we have to worry about what
John Dowd has said publicly on this
network or say what we reported about
Andrew Weissman and back-channel
information from or from Christopher
Steele and text messages and
communications that show that in fact
Christopher Steele was trying to funnel
information to the special counsel
well it might my former colleague John
Dao denied unequivocally today the the
reports that came in regarding the
excerpts of the book that were released
regard a purported meeting that he had
and I had regarding a they called it
basically a reenactment of a calm
sation that never took place and and
John said that that was not correct that
that did not happen it did not happen
with regard to the other issues you
brought up the irregularities in this
inquiry from the outset including the
beginning of it which is the dossier
issue which starts the whole thing of
course that's an issue of long and I
could give you a whole list we don't
know the time to go through that again
look all of that's relevant to the
nature and the scope of this inquiry and
it's just resolution at the end of the
day as I said I am convinced that we're
gonna get it there we're gonna end this
soon but I don't give dates but I will
tell you this I'm not worried about
questions on Russia okay Jay Sekulow
will be interesting to see if this
becomes if you will James Comey to you
know weeks before an election thanks for
being with us